got a grip of its virus ministers racing
in for an emergency meeting on
coronavirus four more cases confirmed
one a schoolchild 40 people in the UK
now have the disease the government on
high alert and people have questions
scholars shut down mr. Williamson should
school shut down mr. Williamson for CSIS
can we contain the virus
are we moving to delay phase can we
contain the virus have you got a message
for the public Minister if you've got
any advice for the public watch your
hands yes I know you can't talk about
what happened in Cobra but we can't
really contain this virus any longer can
we surf look I think you should direct
questions to the health secretary not
not to me but that question today
answered by the PM himself this is a
problem that I think is likely to become
more significant for this country in the
course the next days and weeks and
therefore that we'd be making every
possible preparation for that if and
when it starts to spread as I'm afraid
it looks likely that it will we are in a
position to take the steps that will be
necessary all nations in the UK now
preparing for the situation to escalate
in the coming days the next phase of
this would be what's called the de
leafies and that phase starts when it is
judged by the experts that the infection
has taken hold within the community and
what the purpose of the de leus Venice
is to slow down the spread of the
infection and to lower the peak of
infection the shadow health secretary
thinks the government should give the
NHS an emergency cash injection to help
it cope I do have fundamental concerns
about the capacity of the NHS going
forward we know that critical care beds
were 80 percent occupancy last week we
all know that the NHS is under huge
pressure after 10 years of cutbacks in
austerity we know it hasn't got enough
staff the government's officially in the
contained phase trying still to stop the
spread of the disease but officials
privately admit to me that they can't
contain it
for much longer so what comes next will
they'll move to the delay phase trying
to slow the spread of the disease in
order to buy time for research and limit
the impact on the NHS for now there are
no math school closures cancelling of
sport events or city lock downs but all
of that could come as the government
grapples to contain a global epidemic
this former Minister and practicing GP
worked on pandemic planning when in
government yes there will be a series of
stages yes you could see school closures
yes you could see football stadia being
empty all of those things are possible
which is a specific tweye the minister's
responsible are probably having sleepers
noise ministers planning for the worst
hopefully it won't come to that their
action plan will be published tomorrow
to coincide with the public information
campaign a disease that began thousands
of miles away
now impact in all of our lives better
agree Sky News Westminster